to the square
all the way too close to this rook i
mean that's just looks
okay magnus has given up his queen
no no this is too much i think so has
magnus blunted he's just allowed a check
and now the bl what
we've seen a blunder from the world
champion the black queen is just going
to be taken by white's bishop on the
next turn it's going to be a queen for
only a rook and it's going to be game
over mamajara frowning there
i think magnus missed this last pawn
move he thought the queen would be
captured immediately and black would
have had chances but now look at the
black king too open
and magnus disgusted with himself
yeah white's simply going to bring the
white queen across and it's going to be
checkmate within the next few moves yeah
we talk about it sometimes you've got to
look at checks and captures first but he
forgot to look for checks he looked at
the capture of his queen some if you
give up a queen you assume your opponent
will take it immediately
now the black king is getting chased to
the corner where it will eventually be
trapped what a thrilling match this is
all games ending up with a winner and
it's going to go all the way to
armageddon if shakira and mamjiro does
not plunder something
enormous right now oh and look at magnus
this is huge frustration yes
and also what an unconventional opening
from hamajarov